die welt im griff der pandemie
mittlerweile sind über sieben millionen
menschen mit dem neuen corona virus
infiziert mehr als 400.000 gestorben für
die weltgesundheitsorganisation ist die
gegenwärtige pandemie die bislang größte
herausforderung ihrer geschichte
gleichzeitig gerät sie zwischen die
fronten der weltmächte die wer hat
versagt und muss zur verantwortung
gezogen werden trump wirft der whu vor
dem druck chinas nachgegeben und zu spät
vor dem ausbruch der seuche gewarnt zu
haben er friert die zahlungen der usa an
die whu 1
es häufen sich indizien dass china den
ausbruch der seuche vertuscht und
wichtige informationen zu spät an die bh
weitergegeben hat die whu stand unter
enormen druck von china die sichtweise
der chinesen zu übernehmen und sie nicht
für ihre handlungen zu kritisieren
in taiwan kommen die informationen über
das virus früher an
inoffiziell der inselstaat ist auf druck
chinas weder mitglied der un noch der
whu
in der taiwanischen hauptstadt taipeh
treffen wir dr zum teil zu sie arbeitet
im krisen management des landes gegen
die pandemie eines tages fand einer
unserer public health mitarbeiter eine
nachricht in den sozialen medien
darin stand dass in china menschen an
einer lungenentzündung mit unbekannter
ursache erkrankt sein
die chinesische regierung hat das
zunächst nicht bestätigt aber wir waren
sehr alarmiert und begannen sofort uns
vorzubereiten
seit dem ausbruch des sars virus 2003
der in taiwan fehler opfer forderte
haben die taiwaner ein modernes
frühwarnsystem gegen solchen ausbrüche
entwickelt dazu gehört auch das
beobachten des internets nach
entsprechenden hinweisen
die informationen aus dem netz stammen
von lee valley an einem augenarzt aus
woran er postete informationen auf
rezept um seine kollegen vor der
ansteckungsgefahr zu warnen
lieber lian starb im februar selbst an
cupid 19
wenn ihr angst hinweise wurden bald aus
dem netz gelöscht
er musste seine berichte über das virus
öffentlich widerrufen
ein beleg dafür dass staatliche stellen
in china zumindest auf regionaler ebene
versuchten den ausbruch der seuche zu
vertuschen
taiwan hält es aufgrund von ben youngs
informationen für wahrscheinlich dass es
sich um ein gefährliches virus handeln
könnte weil wir wussten dass es in wohin
wahrscheinlich einen solchen ausbruch
gibt begannen wir ab dem 31 dezember
damit die passagiere aller direktflüge
aus johann auf symptome hin zu
überprüfen
australischer sicht ist die gefahr einer
ansteckung durch das neue virus sehr
wahrscheinlich ein wichtiges indiz ist
für die taiwaner dass die infizierten
ingo hahn isoliert wurden
darauf weisen sie in einer mail hin die
das taiwanische zentrum für
seuchenbekämpfung am 31 dezember an die
whu schreibt
14 januar bei der velo in genf herrscht
noch immer unklarheit darüber wie
gefährlich das virus ist auf twitter
meldet die bhu zunächst das chinesische
experten immer noch keinen klaren
hinweis auf eine
mensch-zu-mensch-übertragung gefunden
hätten
doch noch am selben tag räumt die whu
auf einer pressekonferenz ein
es besteht das risiko eines größeren
ausbruchs eine
mensch-zu-mensch-übertragung wäre nicht
überraschen
vor dem hintergrund unserer erfahrungen
mit saas mails und anderen
atemwegserkrankungen die whu noch ab am
20 januar kommt die offizielle
bestätigung der mensch zu mensch
übertragung aus china am 22
januar tritt ein notfall komitee der whu
unter leitung des generaldirektors
rosada longuet jesus zusammen
es geht um die entscheidung ob der
internationale gesundheitsnotstand
ausgerufen werden soll ist sozusagen die
wichtigste aussage
doch die experten des notfall-komitees
sind sich nicht einig wie hoch die
ansteckungsgefahr des virus tatsächlich
ist ein internationalen notstand
auszurufen ist natürlich nicht eine
sache die man mal so zum frühstück macht
und wenn es dann extra dann sagt man gut
war halt nichts gewesen
die unabhängigen experten die ihr
zusammen haben um die bauern zu beraten
haben da sehr intensiv debattiert über
zwei tages war ursprünglich ein tag
angesetzt
jetzt kommt es auf ihn an der whu
generaldirektor muss entscheiden ob der
notstand ausgerufen wird oder nicht
doch trotz zögert das ist eine
notsituation in china aber es ist noch
kein internationaler gesundheitsnotstand
es könnte jedoch zu einem werden us
präsident donald trump behauptet tross
zögern sei auf druck chinas zustande
gekommen
in einem brief an die whu schreibt trump
am 18
am 21 januar 2020 hat sie wie gemeldet
der chinesische präsident jean ping dazu
gedrängt nicht den internationalen
gesundheitsnotstand ausgerufen
die whu hat diese anschuldigung in einer
presseerklärung zurückgewiesen
[Musik]
28 januar vero generaldirektor zetros
trifft sich in peking mit
staatspräsident schießen
an diesem tag gibt es bereits 2800
infektionen weltweit bei seiner rückkehr
nach genf lobt petrochina ausdrücklich
ich war sehr erfreut und beeindruckt von
detaillierten wissen des präsidenten
über den ausbruch
china hat sich komplett der transparenz
verpflichtet nach innen wie nach außen
wasser trus dazu bewegt china trotzdem
zu loben
antalya ist experte für globale
gesundheit an der johns hopkins
universität als ehemaliger berater
mehrerer us regierungen kennt er die
schwierigkeiten der gesundheits
diplomatie als die bh china über den
grünen klee dafür lobte wie gut es den
ausbruch am anfang der krise angeblich
gemanagt hatte dati whu das obwohl sie
laut hätte protestieren müssen als der
augenarzt massiv unter druck gesetzt
wurde
darum geht es doch die bhu stand selbst
unter enormen druck von china die
chinesen für keine ihre handlungen zu
kritisieren
seit seiner wahl zum generaldirektor der
wto im mai 2017 gilt trotz manchen als
chinas wunschkandidat für den posten
petrus war vor seiner wahl gesundheits
und außenminister äthiopiens eines
landes das von china wirtschaftlich
abhängig ist nach seiner rückkehr aus
china handelt tetris sofort
ich erkläre den internationalen
gesundheitsnotstand wegen des ausbruchs
des neuen corona virus war tetris reise
nach china der preis dafür endlich mehr
informationen über das virus zu erhalten
und whu experten nach china senden zu
dürfen ist man als generaldirektor der
whu dazu gezwungen immer diplomatisch
aufzutreten
ein blick in die vergangenheit zeigt es
geht auch anders ende 2002 erfuhr die
whu aus inoffiziellen quellen von einer
tödlichen krankheit die in einer
chinesischen provinz ausgebrochen war
die chinesen behaupten es handle sich um
eine art grippe
es war jedoch ein corona virus auslöser
für die saas krankheit bald häuften sich
die fälle
die generaldirektorin gro harlem
brundtland von deutliche worte gegenüber
china mit ihrer entscheidung reise
warnungen auszusprechen überschritt sie
ihre kompetenzen und bewahrte so die
welt wahrscheinlich vor einer
katastrophe das 2 jahres budget 2018/19
der whu beträgt circa 6 milliarden
us-dollar
doch sie kann nur über die festen
mitgliedsbeiträge der staaten frei
verfügen
das sind gerade mal 20 prozent ihres
jahresbudgets
die übrigen 80 prozent sind freiwillige
zahlungen von privater und staatlicher
seite
sie sind meistens zweckgebunden die usa
waren seit der whu gründung 1948 ihr
wichtigster stützpfeiler politisch und
finanziell
sollte es dabei bleiben dass die usa die
whu verlassen könnte china seine
machtposition ausbauen
auch in anderen internationalen
organisationen versucht china das vakuum
das die usa unter trump hinterlassen zu
füllen
[Musik]
die chinesen haben eine ganz klare
strategie sie tun das was die
vereinigten staaten in den 70er 80er
jahren gemacht haben oder auch schon
früher als die un eigentlich gegründet
und mit ihnen zitiert haben nämlich die
un für nationale interessen zu nutzen
dazu passte auftritt von camping während
der jahresversammlung im mai 2020 die
chinesen nutzen den rückzug der usa und
versprechen zwei milliarden dollar für
die bekämpfung von kogit 19 hatte die
whu zu wenig macht und möglichkeiten
china zu mehr offenheit zu zwingen
oder war die whu zu spät zu träge zu
unentschlossen
hätte man früher reagieren können
sicherlich natürlich hätte das zu einem
anderen am 11 märz stellt whu
generaldirektor petrus auf einer
pressekonferenz fest
[Musik]
die whu hat den ausbruch rund um die uhr
bewertet und war tief beunruhigt
sowohl von der alarmierenden verbreitung
und der gefährlichkeit des virus als
auch von der alarmierenden
tatenlosigkeit
wir sind deswegen zu dem schluss
gekommen dass coop 19 als pandemie
charakterisiert werden kann
der ausruf einer pandemie ist für die
mitgliedsstaaten der fao der weckruf
mitte märz zehn wochen nach der ersten
meldung an die whu taiwan hat weder den
ausruf der pandemie noch die ausrufung
des gesundheitszustandes am 30 januar ja
nicht einmal die erste pressemitteilung
der whu am fünften januar abgewartet so
kommt taiwan bislang ohne lockdown und
methode zahlen im einstelligen bereich
durch die krise
wenn es erste anzeichen einer epidemie
gibt egal wo auf der welt muss die whu
in der lage sein schnell warnen und
handeln zu können
ohne diplomatische rücksichtnahme ich
glaube nicht dass die whu versagt hat
aber es stellen sich durchaus fragen was
die ersten tage der pandemie betrifft
was da getan oder unterlassen wurde
es ist sehr wichtig zu verstehen was
damals geschehen ist kann zukünftig
besser reagieren zu können und wir
wollen uns ja verbessern und diese
pandemie jetzt die haben wir nicht gut
gemanagt ausgerechnet in der korona
krise ist die
weltgesundheitsorganisation zwischen die
fronten der weltmächte geraten
zu beginn der pandemie hat sie zu lange
gewartet deutlicher vor dem virus zu
warmen jedoch auch schnellere
alarmsignale der whu helfen wenig wenn
die welt darauf nicht angemessen
reagiert
[Musik]